[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Cliff is
with us in Raleigh hi Cliff welcome to
the Ramsey show thank you and it's truly
an honor to be on the air with you guys
you you guys are amazing well thank you
how can we
help okay so I'll try to be brief here
um I have been saving I have two kids
that are 19 and 23 my son is a rising
sophomore at college and my daughter is
in graduate school she has one more
semester to go and thanks to you and
some other good advice I've been saving
in a 529 plan since since they were
babies so I had plenty of money to pay
for most of the tuition um especially
for um my daughter because she got
scholarships as well but anyway but now
there's uh two years left of my co of my
son being in college and one more
semester of my daughter in graduate
school and with my ex I had it set up so
that I paid half like one full year was
mine the other full year was hers but
now she's saying that she doesn't have
the money or she's telling my son that
and so she's trying to force me to use
all of my 529 statement which is totally
in my name and in addition to that my
son who has worked for the past four
Summers he saved about
$10,000 she was trying to force him to
use to drain his entire savings to pay
for this last semester
so I feel kind of bad now we know why
she's the
ex very very difficult most people you
can talk to but she didn't it never was
a conversation it was always one way so
she's broke she makes over well she
makes over $100,000 a year she can still
be broke much that's true okay so we got
two issues one we've got an obstinate ex
who's out of control but that's not the
real issue you can't control the out of
control obstinate X that's why she's the
X so what are we going what are you
going to
do well I I didn't tell her this but I
actually paid for my son's last last
semester fall semester I I told I told
her that she that he used all his money
so that she can't keep coming back to me
to keep paying you know so because if
IID have told her that then she would
say oh well your dad can pay for this
semester coming up you see what I mean
yeah yeah all right so so so um we got
to manipulate her CU she's a manipulator
but uh but aside from that how much is
in the
529 total there's about 28,000 between
both 529 plans not enough to finish the
school for the all all three all three
correct it's not enough correct okay and
then when it's out if she doesn't pay
how are we getting out that's my thing I
don't want them to be in debt she she
can she can make get loans I don't want
them to be in
debt
are either is anybody once again you're
trying to control her but I keep
reminding you she's the
ex we can't control her we can only
control what you do so if you think if
you think telling her that she better be
meet her obligation by the court that
she's supposed to pay because it's a
part of the divorce decree right no no
they're both 18 there's no agreement
this is just this is just being adults
exactly let's work this adults how how
much more are they going to need to
finish well it'll be about 40,000 okay
so we're 12 Grand off what do you
make right now I make about 70 which I
in the past few years i' I've made about
half that so I'm just now starting to
make a little bit of money and your son
and your son has how
much well he had $110,000 saved which he
still has it but I'm hiding it I get all
that I'm trying to figure out what the
reality is not the manipulation the ex
you're spending a lot of energy worrying
about her I'm trying to get you to quit
doing that yeah because if you you he's
got 10 she you got 28 that's 38 you need
40 you're you're done you're done it's
not even a problem you're done cuz
here's the thing you pretty much know I
know and I've only been talking to you
for about 80 Seconds that she's not
going to
pay she's not going to do it
need so I just need to get my son to
drain his savings is she going to do
it I don't I don't know what she's going
to do I really don't I talk and hold on
a sec because you're saying it's not bad
if you're like my son's going to drain
his savings he's paying for his
education and that's good if he's
contributing a little bit he shouldn't
have to drain it if his mother wasn't a
twerp but that's the deal that's besides
the point at this point like like you
said they can't control her um right and
I don't I I would make a run at
manipulating her and just saying it's
your turn but I mean i' make a run at it
but you need to be prepared to start
writing checks cuz I don't think this
check's coming through I I did send her
a certified letter about a month ago
before I called you guys and laid out
kind of basically what I'm telling you
guys was a one page very businesslike
here's what I've paid year half is the
you know and I said that my son is
basically broke now based on her plan so
that's that's right all I've done so is
she going to pay then I don't I really
don't know I don't I hope
I I don't I don't have much
hope I think she has I think she has
displayed her colors and they are very
clear yeah but um but you know so what I
would do is make a run at getting her to
pay but be mathematically and
emotionally prepared to start writing
the checks out of the 28 and out of the
10 okay that's helpful that's painful
but that is helpful well something you
listen here's something the other option
is your kid goes in debt cuz his wife
cuz his mother's an
idiot basically and no that's not okay
yeah not when he's got 10 and you got 28
and you need 40 to finish you can do it
he can do it y'all can pull this off
it's not okay so we're not going to
leave the third the the option of him
going in debt because his mother goofed
up is not on the plan so he doesn't have
to drain his savings no he uses his
savings like Jade said it's called an
investment in your education you're
paying for college well that's okay I
paid for part of my college most of it
as a matter of fact I think all almost
all of it but yeah there you go it's
like yeah and I worked all the time you
start paying for college you'll be more
engaged than you've ever been cuz you
know where your money's going yeah
there's that too so yeah I Cliff I think
you know you're looking for justice and
I don't blame you for that but I don't
think Justice is going to occur here
Justice is she stands up and goes oh I'm
his mom I should keep my word I should
pay my half I'm going to be a grown-up
and adult and take care of my part of
theart
I'm going to have integrity but nothing
you described about this woman indicates
she's actually going to do that um if
you have any hope of that you have more
hope than I do cuz everything you
described about her describes someone
that's not going to follow through on
this so she might but and again I'd give
it a shot it yeah jacking her up and
getting her to do it I don't care if
she's mad I mean let's get her going
let's get her going like that woman I
can tell that woman is drives him crazy
and when she gets him wound up he'll
just he's just spinning his wheels
trying to figure out why won't she do
this why yeah yeah that she she's the ex
for a reason yeah x x x x stay stay far
away XX X XX you know there's a reason
just just get distance distance create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life